I knew so much about the family history
and the inner workings of this family so
at the time I had a book contract and I
started doing routine interviews with
anybody connected to Jose and Kenny
minutes
behind me one of the people I talked to
was John Perdue who had been Jose's
personal assistant at Hertz rent a car
and RCA records
foreign
he would bring up at some point that
Jose Menendez was obsessed with the band
menu and the singer Ricky Martin a
member of menudo
I started thinking to myself why does he
keep mentioning that Jose was obsessed
with Manu you know what's that about
what sexually by the way
and I found out that Manu had a very
unusual story